welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and you're now
locked into the channel where we break
down all the latest movies TV shows
games and comic books throughout this
video we're just going to be discussing
everything that you need to know about
the timeline of The Witcher on Netflix
the events mailee be confused as some
things that happen in Episode four set
up things in Episode one and yeah
there's a lot of time you why me
wibbly-wobbly stuff so we're just gonna
be breaking it down as simply as
possible to show you how the first
season maps out anyway there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to watch the show yet and
don't want to know what happens then I
highly suggest that you turn off now
we're spoiling absolutely everything
here so you might want to check out if
you've not seen the season yet without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for clicking this video now sit back
toss a coin you witch and let's get into
our timeline breakdown okay so the main
thing that you need to know about the
witches timeline is that the show
actually possesses three distinctive
timelines that all center around the
seasons three main characters they are
Geralt yennefer and ciri the season
initially seems to play out in
chronological order with there being a
reference to Siri and gerelds timeline
in the first episode however not
everything is as it seems
this is all prophetic and there's
actually a lot of things that are
predicted in the season such as ciri
dreaming of yennefer which we'll get
into later in this breakdown but we've
kind of just laid everything out from
beginning to end in order to make the
most sense of it the timelines are
deliberately put in place in order to
confuse viewers and sort of drop mini
twists in when you begin to realize that
things on as they seem it's an awesome
way for the storyline to progress and
it's sort of adds a mystique to the
proceedings of the season gerelds
timeline is probably what I'd say is the
main one as he's the only character that
meets both yennefer and ciri however at
some points they're all happening
alongside one another in total they span
across decades but yen's timeline is
actually the one that happens first so
yep yennefer is old I'm talking like
Prince Phillip old I'm saying like my
wife in Borat voice old anyway the first
see her she's a hunchback who tends to a
farm she's pretty much tracked like how
the Dursleys treat Harry Potter and
nobody really likes her she is however a
great example of why you should always
be nice to the ugly girl in school we
all in the hard way I still love you
Lauren Thompson anyway we learn in the
season that yen is half-elf and that her
father died during a genocide known as
the great cleansing in gerelds timeline
they refer to this almost as a legend
and therefore we know it happened a long
time before we ever meet your wit sure
for the first time we know that yen
can't really remember her father all
that well so he probably died when she
was very young
meaning that she arrived at Artoo's er
15 years after the great cleansing we
don't know how long that yennefer stood
there for but she ages very little
between her arrival and ascension so we
can probably guess that it was roughly
between 4 to 5 years however all of this
is happening long long before the birth
of Siri
up to at least 50 years prior yen begins
developing her powers and slowly becomes
one of the most powerful mages in the
land
she is tied to the sorceress though and
must perform tasks for them the
sorcerers are using their mages to
control each kingdom strategically
placing them in order to rule the courts
she wants to go to Orden but this is
refused by her bosses unless she turns
to drastic measures in order to ensure
that she gets her own way during this
she has her appearance fixed and as we
know from The Witcher law all magic
comes with a cost
so in order to receive Beauty she has to
give up her ability to bear children the
procedure ends with her womb being
removed in order to achieve this yin
gets a position in the court of Eden and
she begins working there however this
comes at the annoyance of fran Jilla who
was sent to nilfgaard in yen's place at
this location for Angela begins to
empower the kingdom and we learn that
technologically it begins making leaps
and bounds after her appointment there
we also do know that it's roughly about
the time of yennefer this appointment
that Geralt origins story happens as a
young man he's abandoned by his mother
of a sinner bound by vesemir and trained
to be a witch heir fingers crossed we
get to see Bess Amir next time as there
are rumors that he will be played by
mark hamil that's just some fan casting
no but yeah
I would love to see it and maybe we will
finally get the Luke Skywalker story we
should have got a lot stopped before I
start running from here yennefer begins
working for the court in a position that
spans 30 years here she has a couple of
tragic events happened to her and she
fails to save a mother and a baby which
massively changes her opinion on mages
kingdoms sorcerers and so on it's during
this time that Geralt begins to have
some adventures he meets straggle ball
lifts a strike occurs and so on and so
on this is pretty much where his story
picks up in episode 1 and his timeline
and adventures flow from this point
onwards these tales are immortalized in
songs and for the next couple of decades
he becomes renowned throughout the
witcher land yennefer abandons her post
at the court and begins working
independently though we don't know how
long she does this for roughly though
yennefer timeline takes place over about
the space of 70 years so we can assume
that it was roughly about 10 years yeah
this show is kind of all over the place
and no one ages but that's just what we
can gather from lip service that's
dropped after gaining a reputation and
Geralt attends a royal ball at sintra
Queen kalantay is looking for a suitable
husband for a daughter princess pavetta
and during this time she insults a
representative of nilfgaard which
eventually gives reason for their
invasion later in the timeline but
earlier in the show yeah it's very
confusing in addition to this the court
is sent in the shock when pavetta
reveals that she already has a suitor
named Donny Donny had been cursed at the
age of 13 by a mage but with the help of
Geralt they are able to lift it as a
thank-you a dunny gives Geralt the lure
of surprise which turns out to be
princess ciri who now has a fate tied
with The Witcher Geralt continues
traversing the land and with Jesse er he
discovers a gin bottle in a lake and
from this receives three wishes not long
after he meets yennefer and he binds his
fate to her with his last wish we never
find out what this is however there are
some fan theories online that girl
actually wish that they would have a
baby together this would not only save a
life but it would also make it that one
day she would be able to have children
it also makes their fates tied together
and is probably the most likely theory
that I've seen
though as I've said this has never been
confirmed yen and Geralt begin their
on-again off-again relationship and
separate for a couple more years
however they bump into each other once
more on the adventure involving the
golden dragon this seems too good to be
true and yen realizes that the last wish
by Jerrold probably is behind it she
gets angry and storms off and this is
the last time that the characters meet
in season 1 Geralt goes to sintra and
queen kunti encode tried to trick him
into guarding effects ciri though he
discovers this and is eventually jailed
for it
milf God invades sintra and Queen Kunti
dies before passing she instructs ciri
who is now 14 to go and fight Geralt
during the invasion Geralt goes looking
for her but he's unable to find her and
she flees to the wilderness cahier
searches for her and ciri realizes that
she has incredible powers she goes to
broccoli in and is tricked by a
shape-shifter nilfgaard want her bad and
they're also pretty much ravaging the
entire landscape fringe illa who is now
leading the nilfgaardian army attends
court at r2 user and a civil war happens
it's during this time that the big
battle at the bridge takes place in
which foreign Jilla attempts to take one
that will give her andi Romi's access to
the northern kingdoms this is known as
the Battle of southern Hill and it does
have the potential to turn the tide of
the war it's an awesome action scene
that is definitely one of the highlights
of the show and though it's not
completely carried across just how
instrumental this location will be in
the war defending it is of the utmost
importance yennefer and a squad managed
to save the day and she unleashes all
the powers at once completely decimating
the forces in nilfgaard
and killing many many people this is
Jennifer's last appearance in the season
and after unleashing everything she
disappears during this time Geralt is
badly injured and he's taken care of by
a stranger he has a vision of his mother
of a Senna and in the season finale he
comes across Siri Siri asks you yennefer
is as she's been having dreams about the
character and the show cuts to black
ending the first season
so that's all of the events in the first
season's timeline we did skip over some
of the events just to keep everything
streamlined but that's pretty much
everything you need to know about the
main events in the show we do know that
going forward season two will have a lot
more streamlined timeline and that the
events will be happening in
chronological order finally so no more
head-scratching
I promise well I don't know that for
definite but I'm really hopeful
hopefully this video is helping and I
definitely think the show's narrative us
that it keeps it really engaging and I
loved watching the events unfold in the
way that they did this is a really
unique show made all the more unique
because of its structural layout I had a
lot of fun putting this together and it
was brilliant revisiting the show with a
new understanding of how things were
happening anyway that's everything you
need to know about the timeline of The
Witcher on Netflix if you enjoyed this
video then please give it a thumbs up
and if you want to know more about the
show then check out our breakdown of
everything we know so far about the
second season you've also put together a
full breakdown of the first season which
should be linked at the end so yeah two
great things to watch if you're a witch
you're fan you want to come chat to me
after the video that make sure you
follow me on twitter at definition
whitey will head over to my discord
server which you'd be linked in the
description below
you drop videos on there earlier so if
you want to see stuff before anyone else
and that's the best place to be it's
free adjoining we have an awesome
community so hopefully I see you over
there very soon we're also giving away a
free copy of Joker which is one of our
favorite movies of last year and all you
have to do to be in with the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the timeline in the comment
section below the one is gonna be chosen
the 15th of January and the set will be
shipped out from then to ever get
surprised so best of luck to everyone
who takes part
this is the channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]